you ready
want to get married
ladies and gentlemen Jessie and Emma
learn
screaming
fly off to Alaska okay I'll call you
when I land
hello Mrs Lerner your husband was on a
helicopter that went down in the Pacific
Jesse at first it was so hard to let go
I refused to admit you were gone
but then I started to think that the
good days could be good weeks or good
months I'm finally ready to live again
Emma Sam
[Music]
I guess you all know that I've been
madly in love with Emma for a few years
now the family yeah
hello sweetheart it's Jesse I'm alive
I can't wear that to reunite with your
long-lost husband
made it back to you I tell you how sorry
I was really I'm engaged
you and Jesse had this beautiful life
together and then we all thought he was
dead and you found love again with a
great guy no matter what you do you're
gonna break somebody's heart
that was incredibly verbose but accurate
that was wildly inappropriate I'm gonna
stop no man for God's sakes just keep
talking
the person that she
looks not a person that loves her the
most
Marie so don't go tell him
[Music]
are we really not going to talk about
your husband-in-law I what